Guten Morgen Linus.
Guten Morgen Tim.
Herr Neumann, jetzt sind sie seit hundert Tagen jetzt politischer Präsident. Was haben sie denn so dazu zu.
Es ist großartig, unser Team arbeitet seit seit hundert, also seit dreißig dieser hundert Tage sehr effektiv ähm und wir haben
Es ist großartig, lasst euch nicht von der von der Lügenpresse einreden, dass es hier netzpolitisch nicht voran ginge. Natürlich die Demokraten halten uns zurück mit ihren verschiedenen Gesetzes vor
Schriften und eigentlich bricht alles zusammen, aber wir sind geil.
Logbuch, Netzpolitik Nummer zweihundertundzwanzig auf der Spitze unseres Erfolges. Wir haben alles unter Herr Wallisterkontrolle,
die Bundesrepublik Deutschland. Das ganze politische System richtet sich ausschließlich nach unseren Anweisungen, oder? War das doch, oder?
Unser System läuft wie eine fein abgestimmte Maschine.
Sich wir jetzt grade erst tatsächlich, also es ist ja wirklich so, dass der Tipp diese Intros nicht mit mir abspricht und mir ist wirklich erst gerade so beim Sprechen aufgefallen, dass wir wirklich so ein bisschen Trump Esk äh hier sitzen.
Und irgendwie so, wie war das damals dieser das war oh man jetzt, jetzt fange ich schon an wie Donald Trump hier. Das war doch Irak, ne? Nein, es war Iran,
Nein, in welchem Land war dieser ähm,
war dieser, wo die Amis einmarschiert sind, innerhalb kürzester Zeit alles den Boden gleich gemacht haben und der ähm der Militär Regierungssprecher hier wieder noch so saß, so. Hier sind keine Panzer und hinter dem flogen irgendwie so die ganzen Städte in die Luft.
Irak. Du meinst äh den den Comical Ali meinst du.
Ich bin froh, dass ich das richtig in Erinnerung hatte.
Kann man sich ja heute auch nicht mehr so sicher sein, ne?
Herr Neumann, sagen sie doch mal was zur netzpolitischen Lage. Alles super, Kurs der Freiheit wird, wir werden die Freiheit auch am Hindukusch verteidig.
Mohammad Sahaw. Ja, das war er. Bagdadi, Bob oder Comical Ali.
Ja, ja, er ist Außenminister, wird Informationsminister.
So ungefähr. Ach genau, das war ja noch der also Propagandaministerin ist.
Ja, ja, der hat ja immer diese geilen Pressekonferenzen gehabt. Ich die Amerikaner sterben in den Straßen.
Ja, hier ist alles voller Blut.
Die müsste man dann irgendwann mal alle mal so 'ne Fersehow bringen, aber das ist ja glaube ich schon gestorben, oder? Nee, der, der lebt noch.
Ach nee, das war der richtig, der der Assist, der der ist glaube ich mittlerweile gestorben, oder? Täusche ich mich da auch. Ja, der ist to.
Ich sehe schon die Twitter-Meams jetzt irgendwie Bilder von uns beiden vor irgendwie so rauchenden Ruinen eben so guten Morgen.
Wir haben euch nie dazu aufgefordert, das zu tun.
Tja, so ist das, äh wenn man irgendwie eigentlich nichts in der Hand hat und äh trotzdem den Anschein wahren möchte, man würde ja die ganze Zeit irgendwas tun.
Da bleibt einem nämlich nur der Klick. Aber der Klick, den Klick können wir. Klick äh Klick können wir
Wir haben also nach Veröffentlichung der letzten Folge hatte ich so eine eine Hoffnung, ich dachte boah, es wäre ja super, wenn äh die Token, die bei DSST, bei Data Science in Stories ge,
gespendet wurden, sich verdoppeln würden im Rahmen der Veröffentlichung unserer Sendung und des Aufrufes dort nochmal Tokus zu spenden, weil dadurch ja meine Credibility gegenüber Michael und Markus enorm steigen würde.
Street Kret.
Klickritt.
Cliquability.
Street Clicability und ähm es äh das das Geschadern auch tatsächlich ähm.
Und der Endstand ist jetzt eine Woche später, also letzte Woche hatten sie hundertsechzig Talkens. Jetzt haben sie fünfhundertdreiundsiebzig. Äh das ist also das heißt ja quasi jedes Mal, wenn sich das verdoppelt,
haben sie ja quasi auch eine Verdoppelung in der Geschwindigkeit mit der sie Abfragen machen können
Und jetzt weiß ich nicht, ob alle paar hundert, die jetzt dazu, alle, was ist das? Vierhundertdreizehn, die dazugekommen sind oder vierhundertzehn.
Wirklich von uns kamen, aber keiner oft von Twitter gewesen sein, aber zumindest ein signifikanter Anteil äh wurde da auch durch durch äh uns ver.
Verdienst. Warum lachst du da so.
Ich sehe dich gerade, dass er an deinem Schreibtisch sitzt und und und so eine Mappe herumhältst oder nur wie so die Zahlen drauf sind. Ja, wir haben mehr tun als alle anderen gehabt.
Donald Trump, diese.
Ja, die Electric Map.
Aber jetzt noch, wo er lang erzählt, weißt du noch damals, wir hatten mehr Truckens als alle anderen.
Ohne mich hättet ihr keine.
Hi, in Herited Beast Tokens, also Toral Desast.
Oh Gott.
Inzwischen ist dann auch die dritte äh Story veröffentlicht worden, die ich letzte Woche schon erwähnt hatte, was mir dann nachher auffindet. Ja, dann die drei Stories zu dem Zeitpunkt waren aber nur zwei veröffentlicht worden,
Äh die dritte ist jetzt auch veröffentlicht worden. Das inoffizielle Unterstützernetzwerk der AfD, wo sie sich so die ersten Follower, also quasi einen Account, ein neuer Stern wird geboren
Wer äh folgt als erstes und dann haben sie da mit diesen Leuten gesprochen und äh,
Das ein bisschen dieses komplette Netz einmal durchleuchtet und da nochmal einen schönen Artikel zugeschrieben, auch der ähm amüsant und lesenswert, eine schöne Vermischung aus Datenanalyse und.
Ähm.
Weiterer Beobachtungsgabe, denn ähm da ich glaube an dieser äh Zusammenarbeit hat man auch wieder schön gesehen, du brauchst eben für Daten.
Auch schöne Hypothesen und diese schönen Hypothesen hatten sie und ähm dann eben das findige Team, um die auch, um denen auch nachzugehen. Dann gab's da aber auch einen äh Kommentar zu, den ich mal verlesen möchte. Das ist der Kommentar von Alex,
Das ist ein ziemlich niedriges Niveau. Ein menschliches Twitter-Bot-Netz mit dem Ziel, die API auszuhebeln, zu erstellen. Man setzt sich für Ethik ein, aber diese solle dann bitte nicht,
für sich selbst gelten. Tja, ist ein interessanter, ist eine interessante Idee. Also der, um das kurz nochmal zu erinnern, man spendet dort die Talkens, weil jeder einzelne Talken eine äh Limitierung hat an Abfragen, die an Twitter gestellt werden können.
Und durch dieses äh durch diese Torkenspende,
jedes Mal quasi eine Anzahl von,
Nachfragen pro Sekunde äh oder Minute oder Stunde mehr möglich für das äh Data Science-Team und so können sie schneller äh diese ganzen Daten,
weil man beispielsweise die ganzen Follower eines Accounts nicht mit einem Rique bekommt, beziehungsweise man bekommt vielleicht die Follower, aber man bekommt auf jeden Fall nicht die Infos der Follower,
Ja? Also wenn man quasi das ist, das wächst die Anzahl an Requets, die man stellen muss, wächst sehr schnell exponentiell und man hat aber eine eine harte Grenze, wie viele man pro Zeiteinheit absetzen kann und je mehr,
uns da zur Verfügung stehen. Äh desto schneller geht das eben.
Also ein gewisser Einsicht für die Saison nachvollziehbar. Also ich meine, gelb gelb nein ähm die diese Limits zunächst einmal.
Weil würde, hättest du keine? Dann würde wirklich jeder Arsch äh anfangen durch den kompletten Twitterbaum durchzuspidern und dann hätten die Buchsen auch äh schnell nichts anderes mehr zu tun, als nur,
Auskunft zu geben für Datensammler.
Genau und wer hättest du diese Limitierung nicht, hättest du auch kein Twitter mehr, ne? Also man muss auch ähm diese AP-Limitierung haben,
insbesondere auch den Zweck das Geschäftsmodell zu erhalten, denn Twitter so sehr ähm also diese sozialen Netzwerke funktionieren immer auf der Idee, dass zwar,
alle Daten für die Nutzer zugänglich sind, die in diesem Netzwerk sind, aber nicht alle auf einmal. Denn das ist ja der Kuchen.
Den sie da monetarisieren und das wollen sie behalten,
Insofern kann man auch sagen, dass der scrollen oder äh äh dass äh dass dass,
Raussaugen aller Daten aus einem sozialen Netz ein Angriff,
auf die dessen Geschäftsmodell ist. Deswegen gehen sie da so entschieden gegen vor, dass diese Daten existieren.
Und dass es jemand eine private Instanz gibt, eine privatwirtschaftliche Instanz gibt, die sie hat und monetarisiert äh ist ja ein Fakt. Ähm insofern weiß ich nicht, ob ich ähm
tatsächlich sagen würde, das ist äh ethisch nicht vertretbar, was da getan wird. Das würde ich anders sehen. Ähm jeder Nutzer hat quasi laut AGB das Recht so und so viele Riques pro Zeiteinheit zu machen und mehrere Nutzer sagen, ich
brauche nicht alle davon und äh spende sie der Forschung. Und ähm man kann das jetzt als menschliches Twitter-Bot-Netz äh
bezeichnet, dass die Api aushebelt, man könnte es aber auch einfach äh sehen als jeder.
Jeder Account spendet einen Teil seiner der ihm zur Verfügung stehenden Bandbreite. Ähm,
Und deswegen denke ich nicht, dass das hier etwas Böses ist, ähm was da geschieht.
Böse, böse nicht und es ist auf jeden Fall auch auf gar keinen Fall ein niedriges Niveau. Also das ist einfach mal.
Also mal man kann ja zum Beispiel sehen, wenn wir hier also Ethik äh Ethik sehe ich ja hier den Bezug, ähm ich vermute mal, dass es dass es ein eine Anspielung auf entweder wie auch immer geartete Datenschutzethik ist,
oder halt auch die Hackerethik.
Und ähm da ist ja der der Punkt in der Hackerethik. Alle Informationen müssen frei sein. Misstraue, Autoritäten, fördere Dezentralisierung ähm.
Öffentliche Daten nutzen, private Datenschützen, während so die drei ethischen Aspe,
direkt dazu in Verbindung sehe,
ja, Befreiung von Informationen aus den Krallen der Kapitalisten.
Dezentralisierung in dem man sich die Aufgabe teilt, nicht wirklich, aber eben auch öffentliche Daten nutzen, private Daten schützen, was in einem sozialen Netzwerk ist, ist,
öffentlich,
wird hier eben nur gesammelt. Also ich sehe da keine ähm sehe da tatsächlich keine keine keine ethische Grenze, die mit dieser Analyse überschritten wird.
Also ist mir jetzt keine hakaetische Grenze. Man könnte jetzt nach der Ruhe diskutieren, ob es stadthaft ist äh hier der AfD äh hinterher zu forschen, ja.
Und wieso denn nicht? Also man.
Kann man diskutieren, also äh ich meine hier steht hier das Ziel sei die API auszuhebeln. Ich würde sagen, das Ziel ist es hier eher die AfD auszuhebeln. Darüber kann man dann nochmal diskutieren, ob das jetzt irgendwie ethisch geboten ist, aber da kann ich nur sagen
sorry ähm also man könnte den den Machenschaften sollte man schon mal auf die Spur kommen.
Das könnte man auch mit anderen Parteien machen und wenn man da ähm wenn man da Informationen findet.
Die berichtenswert sind, dann würde ich das auch bei anderen Parteien genauso gut heißen,
Denn wenn Leute versuchen uns,
einem signifikanten Teil unserer Öffentlichkeit zu täuschen, dann ist es das Richtige, äh dass sich
sich anzuschauen und zu untersuchen und diese Erkenntnisse öffentlich zu machen. Und wenn jetzt halt die einen sagen, okay, wir gucken auf die AfD, hindert niemand, die anderen daran zu gucken, was weiß ich, wir schauen auf die Linken, auf die SPD, auf die CDU, CDU oder auf die Grünen
oder auf die FDP, um noch so eine Partei zu nennen, die weniger vertreten ist. Ähm insofern, ich sehe da ähm,
Kein moralisches Problem oder ein kein ethisches Dilemma.
Gut, ein äh ethisches, moralisch-ethisches Dilemma. Offenbar bei der Bundeswehr.
Vor allem also vor allem kriege ich persönliches Feedback. Ähm dass äh das aber überhaupt nicht geht,
dass wie wir die Bundeswehr hier als einen möglichen Arbeitgeber von vielen,
darstellen würden. Vielleicht muss man nochmal kurz darauf hinweisen, dass du als äh Soldat äh ne, das ist nicht irgendwie so ein Arbeitsvertrag, wo du äh sagen kannst,
Ach äh heute bin ich krank
Ich gehe heute nicht an die Front, ich habe Husten oder sowas, ne? Oder äh ich kündige Chef oder da habe ich keinen Bock drauf, sucht euch jemand anderen oder,
Ähm, habe ich hier überhaupt noch irgendwelche Grundrechte, ne? Du trittst äh einen signifikanten Teil deiner Grundrechte ab. Du kommst aus wenn du dich da verpflichtest, nicht mehr raus und äh die schicken dich halt auch gerne mal äh in
Ins Ausland, wie es da so schön heißt äh und schicken dich durch ein Mienenfeld, ne? Das ist äh ist nicht irgendwie ein Arbeitgeber, wie jeder andere auch
darauf wurde ich gebeten auch noch einmal äh,
hinzuweisen, dass ihnen das es eine ganz andere Qualität von Lebenswegentscheidung ist, äh sich für die Bundeswehr zu melden, als für äh irgendetwas anderes.
Gut, aber das ist ja jetzt nicht der Kernpunkt äh unseres Segments, sondern äh Kernpunkt Segments ist die Tatsache, dass es hier offenbar ein.
Soldaten gegeben hat, der äh in der Bundeswehr äh verdingt ist, konkret sogar in diesem deutsch-französischen äh Gemeinschaftsbataillon und.
Der hat den Marsch durch die Institutionen gemacht.
Ähm.
Ja und das äh wurde ja nun auch breit äh berichtet. Wir müssen das jetzt hier auch glaube ich nicht unbedingt in der vollen Breite alles äh wiedergeben und im Detail, weil uns die, glaube ich, die Details auch dann äh gar nicht so sehr vorliegen. Tatsache ist, äh dieser Mensch hat sich,
Als Flüchtling registrieren lassen.
Asylbewerber und hat auch irgendwie äh ich weiß gar nicht, hat er Asyl beantragt, glaube ich, ja. Und ähm wurde auch akzeptiert.
Obwohl da ja auch äh Gespräche geführt werden, wo er wohl äh auf Französisch kommuniziert hat, konnte er sich irgendwie erfolgreich als äh,
katholischer Syrer ausgeben. Ja und wurde einfach akzeptiert während er halt zeitgleich,
Soldat war. Und jetzt sind sie ihm irgendwie auf die äh Schliche gekommen und stellt sich raus, ist irgendwie jemand, der dem rechten äh Gedankengut doch wohl sehr nahe steht und der Terroranschläge äh geplant hat oder zumindest Listen äh vorliegen hatte,
wo
ja potenzielle Anschlagsziele oder andere Leute, die nicht in den Kram passen gelistet waren. Und jetzt ist diese Person kassiert worden, was vielleicht ganz gut ist,
und ähm das Ganze prallt auf unsere Sendung,
nachdem wir jetzt in den letzten beiden Sendungen so ausführlich über ja das ethische, moralische Wohl und Wehr
von Bundeswehrsoldaten resoniert haben und wie äh sehr mit dem Grundgesetz verbunden diese Unternehmern und ist oder nicht ist.
Tja, also zumindest eine,
eine Organisation, die auf dieser Todesliste des Herrn Franko Hans A steht, äh sind unsere Freunde vom Zentrum für politische Schönheit
äh die wurden darüber ähm in Kenntnis gesetzt äh vom Berliner Landeskriminalamt, denn irgendwie nachdem sie den Typen irgendwie eingesackt haben, haben sie die Wohnung durchsucht, da gab's eben eine Liste mit,
wen er so alles beabsichtigt zu töten oder töten könnte oder wer es verdient hätte. Und da befand sich eben auch das Zentrum für politische Schönheit,
darunter.
Anrufe, die man nicht bekommen möchte.
Ich stelle mir sie gerade vor, so die Kollegen. Hallo Polizei, wie war's nicht? Wir haben nichts gemacht und eben so. Nee, nee, wir wissen aber, wir wollten ihnen nur sagen, so, sie waren auf der Todesliste eines äh eines rechten Terroristen so,
Ja, das sind echt so Anrufe, na ja, will man die haben oder nicht, vielleicht ist es besser, die zu bekommen.
Passiert ja auch öfter mal, ich also es passiert tatsächlich öfter mal im aktivistischen Umfeld, dass man dann eben auf äh auf irgendeiner Liste landet,
wahrscheinlich ist es in dem Fall angenehm wenigstens auf der Liste einer Person gestanden zu haben die wahrscheinlich und deren Hintergründe wahrscheinlich jetzt.
Wer weiß? Vielleicht hoffentlich dingfest gemacht wurden, wobei sicher in Deutschland regelmäßig herausstellt, dass so Nazistrukturen dann doch gar gar nicht nur verwirrte Einzeltäter sind.
Insofern kann man hoffen, dass es äh dass das ZPS irgendwie in Sicherheit bleibt.
Aber ja, auch die rechten äh engagieren sich im Marsch durch die Institutionen und ähm es wird auch berichtet, dass sie spätestens äh zweitausendvierzehn konkrete Anhaltspunkte dafür hatten, dass dieser Typ ähm,
rechtes Gedankengut vertritt. Unter anderem in seiner Abschlussarbeit an der französischen Militäruniversität irgendwie in Länge und Breite rechtsradikale Thesen vertreten hat
schon interessant. Wie wie das so bei der Bundeswehr oder beim Militär aussieht.
Ja, das ist natürlich extra beunruhigend, nicht, weil das ähm im Prinzip genau an unsere Diskussion anschließt, die wir hier hatten. Ähm wäre das jetzt sozusagen ein O, wir hatten ja keine Ahnung äh,
wer hätte das gedacht? Man konnte ja nicht ahnen, Moment gewesen,
Ja, dann dann habe ich so den Benefit auch verdaut, so dann könnte ich halt sagen, ja okay, alles klar. In jeder Organisation hast du Leute, die mal so quer schlagen
Aber wenn dann halt mit zwei Jahren Vorlauf äh etwas so halböffentlich schon anklang und sind dann halt äh keine entsprechenden Maßnahmen ergriffen worden, dass äh mal weiter
zu analysieren, dann wird's natürlich schwierig. Jetzt weiß ich nicht,
Wie sie ihm eigentlich wirklich auf die Stiche gekommen sind und vielleicht ist das ja auch der Weg, über dem sie ihm letzten Endes auf die schliche äh gekommen sind und dann wäre das auch schon wieder okay.
Kann man schwer beurteilen. Ich denke mal, hier muss man auch mal ein bisschen abwarten, bis da ein bisschen mehr Faktenlage ist, als so ein paar Artikel, die jetzt erstmal die Geschehnisse zusammentragen.
Ihr seht, wir haben das nicht als unser Kernthema, es hat auch mit Netzpolitik wenig zu tun, aber weil wir in letzter Zeit so viel äh uns mit Militär auseinandergesetzt haben, konnten wir zumindest die dieses Geschehnis nicht unerwähnt lassen.
Und schweigen jetzt auch wieder zu.
Ein weiteres Thema, was nur peripher netzpolitisch ist, ist das Gesetz zur Änderung des Strafgesetzbuches, nämlich zum Zwecke der Stärkung des Schutzes von Vollstreckungsbeamten und,
Rettungskräften. Da möchte ich nochmal drauf eingehen, weil wir uns ja mit Herrn Heiko Maas,
in letzter Zeit wieder öfter auseinandergesetzt haben und ich ja inzwischen den Eindruck habe, dass Heiko Maas eine ganze Menge gefährlicher Heißluftgesetze so durchpeitscht.
Für dies objektiv kein Anlass gibt. Könntest du vielleicht mal ganz kurz schauen, Tim während ich hier noch kurz erzähle, worum es geht? Ob und wann dieses Gesetz nun vom Bundestag beschlossen wurde.
Ähm das habe ich nämlich vergessen zu googeln. Also einleitend zur Begründung dieses Gesetzes heißt es, die Zahl der täglichen Angriffe auf Polizisten und Rettungskräfte steigt. Polizisten werden alltäglich brutal attackiert,
Ob von rechten Rechtsbürgern oder Linken, Autonomen auch mit Waffen,
Der Bürger denkt sich natürlich, das kann doch nicht etwa legal sein. Es kann doch nicht sein, dass Polizisten angegriffen werden.
Und sie und nichts dagegen äh getan wird, das muss man doch verbieten,
Und es dachte sich natürlich auch Heiko Maas in völliger Ignoranz dessen, dass es selbstverständlich verboten ist und auch stark bestraft wird
Wenn du äh wenn du versuchst einen Polizisten Körper zu verletzen, ja? Aus eigener Erfahrung kann ich sagen, dass das eine der wenigen Sachen,
Und dann sagen wir mal, wenn wir den Dingen die Gesamtanzahl der Körperverletzungen in Deutschland nehmen.
Würde ich sagen wenn wir uns dann den das Subset, das sehr geringe Subset anschauen von denen wo eine Körperverletzung auch zu einer Verurteilung geführt hat, denn der größere Teil der Körperverletzung in Deutschland bleibt mehr oder weniger ungesühnt.
Ähm dann äh würde ich sagen, dass die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass das bei Polizisten ähm,
belangt wird, einfach mal sehr, sehr viel höher ist. Also du hast
effektiv, wenn du einen Polizisten angreifst, echt Schwierigkeiten aus der Nummer nochmal rauszukommen, während wenn du einfach über die Straße gehst und einmal auf die Schnauze haust und weitergehst, du relativ geringe Chancen hast, dafür ernsthafte Probleme zu bekommen.
Was ich ja auch äh sehr,
bedauere. Nun ähm Heiko Maas sagt, er möchte gerne einen besonderen Schutz der Staatsgewalt haben und zwar diesen ausweiten,
tägliche Angriffe, weil sie ein innewohnendes, erhöhtes Gefährdungspotent Potential äh haben und deswegen stärker sanktioniert werden sollen.
Also sollen die Paragraphen hundertdreizehnhundertvierzehnhundertfünfzehn STGB geändert werden. Fokus liegt hier auf ähm,
Hundertdreizehn. Früher war es so, dass man äh quasi in
Also in der Geschichte des Paragraphen hundertdreißig äh zitiere jetzt eine Analyse von Johannes Busch von der Ruhruniversität Bochum, der das auf dem äh Portal,
Silip oder den beim Silip-Institut veröffentlicht hat. Er sagte, man hat früher den Leuten zugute gehalten, dass sie typischerweise einem Stress oder Erregungszustand unterliegen, in dem es leicht zu reflexartigen Überreaktionen kommen kann,
Ne? Also wenn du in so einer, sagen wir mal, in so einer Verhaftungssituation bist und die Polizei äh weiß nicht, fällt über dich her und knüppelt dich nieder, dann kann das sein, dass du mal eben versuchst, den Arm schützend zu heben und dabei den Oberschenkel eines Polizisten streifst und ähm,
der dann sagen könnte, du hättest ihm auf den Oberschenkel gehauen, aber dass man sagt, okay, pass auf so ein bisschen so, also eine, ein, ein leichtes Maß an Gegenwehr,
akzeptieren wir so, aber Widerstand gegen Vollstreckungsbeamte wäre quasi dann in dem Moment, wo du dich wirklich aktiv,
Verhaftung widersetzt, um dich schlägst, ja und auch wirklich triffst und quasi eine ähm,
eine Verletzung hervorruf. Mit der, ja, du zeigst mit dem Finger auf.
Das Gesetz wurde am.
Donnerstag beschlossen.
Am siebenundzwanzigst.
Das wollte ich nur äh wissen. Äh mit der geplanten Neuregelung wird nun diese Strafbarkeit ausgeweitet und zwar in zwei Richtungen.
Zum einen gab war der Straftatbestand ursprünglich beschränkt auf konkrete Vollstreckungssituationen.
Und wird jetzt aufgeweitet mit den Paragraphen hundertvierzehn, der ähm die,
Tatbestandsalternative täglicher Angriff herauslöst und bei sämtlichen Diensthandlungen von Vollstreckungsbeamten unter Strafe stellt. Merken, es gibt irgendwie den äh Begriff täglicher Angriff.
Und jetzt muss man sich überlegen, was ist denn ein täglicher Angriff? Und in der juristischen Definition, die hier von allen Gelehrten vertreten wird, ähm genügt für einen täglichen Angriff bereits eine gewaltsame Einwirkung,
Wobei es weder zu einer Verletzung gekommen noch eine solche gewollt sein muss. Also ich habe weder die Absicht, dich zu verletzen,
noch verletze ich dich. Das ist dein täglicher Angriff. Also offenbar kannst du nicht niederschwelliger sein. Ich glaube das einzige was noch niederschwelliger ist
Vorsicht der Laie spricht, wäre dann Beleidigung, ne? Weil ich bei Beleidigung ja auch immer denke, ist auch so ein Beispiel, ne? Beleidigungen, es gibt immer einen, der beleidigt und einen, der sich beleidigen lässt,
ja? Und ähm.
Oder beleidigt fühlt.
Oder der sich beleidigt fühlt, ja? Und Polizisten sind äh,
äh sehr empfindlich in diesem Bereich und äh somit die einzige Bevölkerungsgruppe, die auch sehr erfolgreich damit ist, ähm,
im Falle einer Beleidigung äh irgendwelche Schmerzensgelder für das erlittene Leid äh äh zu erhalten wären, wenn jetzt jemand zu mir irgendwie was sagt. Äh ich
eigentlich kaum eine Chance habe. Also Beleidigung ist ein Straftatbestand oder eine eine Delikt, was eigentlich nur gegenüber offiziellen.
Du bist ja auch ein Netzpolitiker, du steckst ja auch alles weg.
Ich kann das, ich bin ja, ich habe ja eine Seelausstahl, mit mir kann man's ja machen, aber mit so einem zarten Polizisten, ne, der der sich ja extra so eine äußere Schale anlegen muss, weil er so ein sensibler Mensch ist, da geht das eben schneller. So, ich meine,
Ähm so jetzt.
Hör auf, Tim, ich zeige dich an. Also ähm also wird aus.
Der tägliche Angreif ist, wenn ich sozusagen irgendwie rückwärts gehe und rein zufällig in einen Polizisten reinlaufe und ihn Verletzte haben und ohne das gewollt zu haben.
Im Eifer des Gefechtes einer Demonstration oder eines überfüllten Maifestes in Berlin
werde ich in deine Richtung gedrängt und schubse dich achtlos beiseite. Du stolperst nicht und wirst nicht verletzt. Ich hatte nicht die Absicht, dich zu schubsen oder dir zu schaden.
Trotzdem, dann ist das ein täglicher Angriff. Ähm.
So, natürlich, das erfasst natürlich auch die versuchte Körperverletzung. Die gab's aber schon, ne? Also ich wir reden hier nicht davon, dass es strafbar wird, dass jemand zu einem Polizisten geht und versucht,
den zu verletzen. Ja, also in dem Moment, wo du die, wo du Schädigungsabsicht hast, bist du ja sowieso sowieso im Bereich der versuchten Körperverletzung. Auch da muss der Polizist nicht verletzt werden,
Ist ja auch schwierig, wenn der gepanzert ist, aber ne, das heißt also, du kannst, du kommst sofort in den, auch heute schon in den strafbaren Bereich, wenn du versuchst, einen Polizisten zu verletzen, ist ja auch im Zweifelsfall richtig so.
Aber wir sind quasi bei täglicher Angriff darunter. Ähm.
Und äh jetzt geht's weiter. Jetzt kommen wir wieder in diesen Maßbereich. Da diese mittlerweile aber auch in Paragraph zweihundertdreiundzwanzig Absatz zwei unter Strafe gestellt sind, bleiben als relevante Konstellationen, die nicht bereits von anderen,
Beständen erfasst werden, nur noch Handlungen,
unterhalb dieser Versuchsschwelle bleiben, weil sie entweder ungeeignet sind oder eine Verletzung gar nicht beabsichtigt war. Das heißt also, ne, der ähm,
Der Autor stellt hier heraus, dass wieder einmal alles schon abgedeckt ist. Außer dieser Bereich, der eben
ohne Beschädigung, ohne Schädigungsabsicht und ohne Verletzung.
Stattfindet. Und nennt selber das Beispiel auch hier was äh einheitlich zitiert wird, ein leichtes Schubsen ohne Verletzungsvorsatz wäre somit schon tat tatbestandsmäßig. Und würde die Rechtsfolge des neuen Paragraphen hundertvierzehn SGSTGB,
auslösen. Okay, also ab dann schon Strafe. Polizist berühren schwierig. Ähm,
Zum anderen erfolgt durch die Reform eine deutliche Erhöhung der Mindeststrafe, ein täglicher Angriff soll zukünftig nach den neunhundertvierzehn SDGB mit mindestens drei Monaten Freiheitsstrafe bestraft werden,
Ähm der Bundesratsentwurf des Saarlandes aus dem vergangenen Jahr sah immerhin noch ein
in einem minderschweren Fall eine erhöhte Mindeststrafe vor, die sonst bei Tatbeständen mit erhöhter Mindeststrafe übliche Möglichkeit, um im Rahmen der Strafzumessung eine einzelfallbezogene Strafhöhe zu finden, fehlt nun
vorliegenden Regierungsentwurf. Das heißt, dass die Mindestfreiheitsstrafe von drei Monaten durch die Gerichte nicht unterschritten werden, dürfte.
Was in keinem Verhältnis zu den erfassten Fällen steht. Wie gesagt, wir reden hier nicht von äh Reichsbürger,
schießt mit seiner selbstgebauten Gummipistole auf einen Polizisten oder so, ne? Das ist schon immer illegal gewesen, das soll auch illegal sein und alles gut, ne? Sondern wir reden hier quasi von äh nicht erfolgter Schädigung bei nicht gegebener Absicht der Schädigung
und das ist echt ein.
Ich finde es aber schon ein bisschen bedenklich, dass so diese diese grassierenden Schubsmops jetzt so in Schutz nimmst, ja? Also die ziehen durch die Parks und äh schubsen einfach.
Arme Polizisten und dafür sollen sie nicht in in Kerke kommen und bei Wasser und Brot vor sich hinsiechen.
Drei Monate knast, bitte. Also ich boah da musst du wirklich vorsichtig sein. Also das ist so ein.
Jetzt war er auch schon vorbestraft.
So etwas ist ein Willkürparagraph, ne? Das ist.
Auch schon vorbestraft.
Bist du nicht erst ab sechs Monaten vorgest.
Weiß ich nicht genau.
Gucken wir mal ich glaube für Vorbestrafung brauchst du sechs Mona.
Naja, steht auf jeden Fall eine Akte kommt bei jeder Polizeiüberprüfung, wird das irgendwie erstmal äh gezeigt, jede äh Autokontrolle haben die dann erstmal Schubspolizisten.
Eine Person gilt in Deutschland als vorbestraft, sobald gegen sie eine Strafe in einem Strafprozess ausgesprochen oder einen Strafbefehl verhängt wurde und diese Maßnahme rechtsrechtlich geworden und nicht getilgt worden ist, auch eine Verurteilung als auf Bewährung gilt als Vorstrafe. Ja gut, dann wärst du,
meiner Lestart vorbestraft. Ey, Großenbogen, um jeden Polizisten machen.
Darf man gar nicht mehr berühren, nichts.
Also ne, das ist so ein richtiger, so ein richtiger Willkür-Paragraph ähm.
Du hast ja ohnehin schon, ich meine, mit der versuchten Körperverletzung hast du ohnehin schon ein sehr gutes, probates Mittel, das Polizisten ja auch,
Regelmäßig versuchen geltend zu machen vor Gericht, also der,
Klassiker ist, wenn dir irgendwie Polizeigefahr wieder äh Polizeigewalt widerfährt und du zeigst das an, kriegst du postwendend äh irgendwie versuchte Körperverletzung, Widerstand gegen Vollstreckungsbeamte und das gesamte Programm,
und ähm erstaunlicherweise sind die Polizisten in großen Gruppen,
in der Lage sich sehr genau und übereinstimmt an das Geschehen zu erinnern, wenn es dann vor Gericht geht das heißt so also der Gewalt von Polizei bist du ohnehin relativ ähm.
Schutzlos ausgeliefert. Ähm in diesem Falle ähm bist du echt gut beraten, um Polizisten einfach nur noch einen großen,
Bogen zu machen.
Es gibt breite breite Kritik, republikanische Anwältin und Anwälte für eine humanistische Union, Beruf, deutscher Richterbund, neue Richtervereinigung, deutscher Ansatz, Anwaltsverein alle.
Sind dagegen, alle kritisieren's, ne? Heiko Maas wieder taub und muss man jetzt mal was tun.
Und schafft halt wieder so eine, so eine also eine es ist halt niemandem geholfen so. Dadurch so und,
Niemand sagt, dass jetzt irgendwie äh Polizisten Gewalt ausgesetzt sein sollen in ihrem in der Ausübung ihres Berufes so
es gibt ruppige Situationen, wo zu erwarten ist, dass die ruppig sind, da gehen die mit ordentlicher Panzerung und Bewaffnung rein.
Es ist vor allem eine Umkehr des des Gewaltmonopolprinzips, wie wir es bisher einfach äh in Geltung hatten in der Bundesrepublik Deutschland. Weil es war bisher ja sogar so.
Dass Polizisten gerade mehr zugemutet wurde,
weil sie eben das Gewaltmonopol haben und weil sie halt in der Lage sind äh Drucksituationen zu erzeugen, in denen halt die normalen Bürger, die eben dieses Gewaltmonopol nicht haben äh.
Ich weiß nicht genau, wie es formulieren soll. Nachteil ist jetzt nicht die richtige Formulierung, aber du bist halt ähm.
Du siehst dich damit halt konfrontiert und Polizisten hatten bisher rechtlich halt eher mehr hinzunehmen.
Ja? Weil so ein, so ein, so ein Widerstand aus solchen Situationen eben sehr nachvollziehbar ist bei Demonstrationen et cetera.
Im Prinzip wird das jetzt hier einfach umgedreht und das kriegen die Leute jetzt deutlich mehr Rechte eingeräumt, die sowieso schon bis alle die Zähne bewaffneter äh rumstehen. Also es ist äh absurd.
Also das ist echt so, da da was jetzt passieren wird ist.
Ne, machen wir uns nichts vor. Gewalt äh entsteht aus Emotionen, Situationen bei Demonstrationen sind häufig ähm,
sagen wir mal angeheizt, angeerhitzt und es kommt zu ruppigen Situationen in der Auseinandersetzung zwischen Bürger und Polizei äh und das regelmäßig.
Das ist äh nicht schön, aber das ist eben auch Realität. Und ähm wenn dann irgendwie Leute grün und blau geprügelt werden, weil wieder mal irgend so ein Polizist ausrastet, dann haben die heute schon sehr eingeschränkte Möglichkeiten.
Ähm da Gerechtigkeit zu finden vor Gericht, weil Polizisten sich dann eben äh.
In ihren,
In ihren Aussagen absprechen, weil sie schon jetzt äh gesetzlich und was das äh was ihre Kraft angeht
bevorteilt sind und das ist unter um ein gewisses Ungleichgewicht kann da gesellschaftlich durchaus
erwünscht sein, weil man ja eben auch am Ende möchte, dass die Polizei Durchsetzungskraft hat,
Dazu gehört aber eben nicht, dass die Polizei einen Willkürparagraphen hat, wo du weder Schädigungsabsicht noch erfolgte Verletzungen brauchst, um Leute drei Monate in Knast zu zu werfen. Das ist nicht mehr witzig,
So, das ist irgendwie äh da da hast du Verhältnisse, die möchtest du wirklich nicht haben. Und das ist nicht das ändert auch nichts daran
dass Polizisten teilweise massiven Angriffen ausgesetzt sind und dass diese teilweise massiven Angriffe eben auch massiv geahndet werden und wurden. Es ist nicht so, als würden wir Polizisten auf die Straße schicken. Die würden jeden Abend weich geprügelt nach Hause kommen und könnten sich nicht wehren,
Wie ist Rainer Wendt, der übrigens gar kein echter Polizist ist? Ähm.
Sondern,
ein hoch hochdotierter Lobbyist und es ist eine Schande für jede für jeden Polizisten, dass die diesen Typen immer noch als Bundesvorsitzenden der deutschen Polizeigewerkschaft haben, aber das müssen die selber klären. Vielleicht kriegt man den ja durch einen kleinen Tät,
Angriff mal aus dieser Position rausgeschubst. Mit dem kann man's ja machen, ist ja kein echter Polizist.
Der sagte in einer öffentlichen Anhörung des Rechtsausschusses Polizistinnen,
Fühlten sich gedemütigt, wenn sie Opfer von Gewalt geworden seien und es dann kein oder ein mildes Urteil gebe. Da musste ich dann aber dann doch schon herbeschmunzeln. Denn.
Ich kenne Menschen, ja. Äh äh die Opfer von Polizeigewalt geworden sind
Und ich meine, kleine Hausaufgabe für die geneigten Hörenden
Such doch mal raus, wie viele Leute, wie viele Verurteilungen von Polizisten es im letzten Jahrzehnt gab, weil sie Gewalt gegenüber einem Zivilisten angewendet haben oder wo da irgendjemand also im Zweifelsfall irgendwo
hinterm Komma.
Diese Verfahren werden wie gesagt in der Regel ähm eingestellt und mit Gegenklagen, Gegenanzeigen überzogen. Wenn du in Deutschland Opfer von Polizeigewalt bist, dann kannst du irgendwie
adäquate Methode damit umzugehen ist runter zu schlucken und mit Freunden oder Therapeuten darüber zu reden über diese Demütigung die dir da widerfahren ist, weil,
da hast du garantiert keinen keine Chance gegen vorzugehen. Da hast du einfach nur,
Also mir ist irgendwie in den letzten zwanzig Jahren ein Fall bekannt, wo ein Polizist mal äh äh einen auf den Sack bekommen hat. Und der hatte, der hatte, der hat einen auf den Sack bekommen, weil,
Er Streit hatte mit dem Kamerapolizisten. Weißt du wie das, also es gibt ja diese Kamerapolizisten, ne
die dann immer filmen und die haben natürlich die allgemeine ähm
Haltung, dass sie dann, wenn die Polizisten den Knüppel rausholen, auf einmal hinten ein Eichhörnchen sehen und das filmen, ne? Da, damit du halt möglichst wenig Knüppeleinsatz auf diesen Videos hast, da, weil die Videos werden ja angefertigt
um Demonstranten der versuchten Körperverletzung zu überführen,
Und äh das war ein Fall, wo die sich irgendwie gezankt hatten oder sowas und der Kamerapolizist, ich dachte, ach weißte was, so wie du hier gerade diesen Typen und die da knüppelst, da halte ich jetzt einfach mal drauf
Ja, der Polizist war dann die längste Zeit Polizist gewesen und deswegen äh sind die Polizisten, die die Kamera haben immer äh,
beliebt im Team kriegen Weihnachtsgeschenke.
Alles schon gesehen. Okay, hier nochmal ein weiteres Beispiel für eine klassische Marsh
maßische Gesetzgebung äh als kleinen Ex-Kurs hier äh mit netzpolitisch höchstens in dem Rahmenbezug, weil es sich hier um einen weiteren
Angriff auf unsere Grund- und Bürgerrechte handelt, wenn demnächst die Hälfte der Demonstranten für drei Monate weggekerkert wird, weil sie irgendwie gegen Polizisten gelaufen sind, aus Versehen.
So jetzt gibt es eine eine Debatte um,
Hackereien. Wir hatten ja hier schon viel äh über den Cyber War den sogenannten äh berichtet und wie sich jetzt alle rüsten und wie sie alle
versuchen sich dort aufzustellen. Wobei dann im Einzelnen immer nicht so ganz klar war,
wie man sich denn jetzt eigentlich rüstet, beziehungsweise für was man sich denn jetzt eigentlich rüstet und wenn man jetzt nochmal kurz Blick auf die Bundeswehr Cyberwehrdiskussion haben, nun gilt ja die Bundeswehr auch mals,
Verteidigungsarmee. Man muss sich halt fragen, wird sie das auch in.
Im Cyber äh äh sein und wie ist das eigentlich mit den anderen, die darunter leiden, weil es ja jetzt auch nicht so, dass die Bundeswehr
Das Hauptangriffsziel äh von Cyberattacken als solche wäre zu müssten, liegt uns eine Information nicht vor und ähm.
Opfer sind ja eigentlich eher Unternehmen, primär, teilweise eben auch die Behörden. Wie soll man jetzt damit umgehen? Ich weiß nicht, wo diese Diskussion jetzt aber mal herkommt, aber es gibt ja eine,
dicke Serie auf der Süddeutschen.
Ja, das wurde von Hakan Tan Riverdi ähm aufgegriffen und behandelt und die also eher ähm,
zeichnet er einfach nach, dass äh Unternehmen dieses Thema besprechen, dass die äh dass die Bundesregierung dieses Thema bespricht und dass man sich jetzt quasi darüber Gedanken macht, so okay, was ist mit,
ähm Cyber-Gegenschlägen, ne? Können dürfen wir das, dürfen wir das nicht? Ähm die momentane Rechtslage ist relativ klar, darfst du nicht. Hack, Hacking ist not aload. In the German Lands,
dass,
Dass ich jetzt, dass man sich deshalb in Deutschland darüber Gedanken macht, okay, wenn wir das, wenn wir dafür eine Rechtsgrundlage schaffen wollen,
Für wen würden wir das denn tun? Ja, da kämen natürlich die äh die Bundeswehr in den Sinn, da käme das BSI in den Sinn.
Ähm man könnte so sowas wie so ein Cybernotwehr äh Paragraphen machen.
Oh je.
Ähm.
Digital geschubst worden.
Täglicher Cyberangriff.
Ne, aber.
Ab in den Knast.
Die Frage ist so.
Warum ich die philosophisch oder oder warum ich die hier einfach mal offen diskutieren möchte ist in meinem beruflichen.
Kontext.
Kommt das schon mal vor? Das beispielsweise man im Rahmen einer Forensik oder im Rahmen irgendeiner Untersuchung.
Kenntnis erlangt darüber, wo zum Beispiel was zum Beispiel ein Command Control Server ist und.
Man natürlich vielleicht sich überlegt, wie wäre das denn, wenn wir mal gucken, ob wir den aufkriegen.
Und vielleicht mal schauen welche unserer Daten dahin geflossen sind oder die mal davon wieder löschen. Ähm und da vielleicht mal äh zurück cybern.
Die legale öffentliche Situation sieht vor, dass man in diesem Moment aufhört.
Und sagt, okay, die Forensik ist abgeschlossen, das war der C und C und wir wissen nicht, wem der gehört.
Aber es kann natürlich könnte, natürlich wäre ja denkbar, dass äh ein Auftraggeber sagt, hör mal, Jungs, ähm.
Wenn ihr jetzt weitermachen würdet und ich euch das niemals in Auftrag gegeben hätte.
Und ihr mir das auch nie offiziell berichtet und sich die Tage, die ihr dafür braucht, aber irgendwo auf euren Rechnungen mit anderen Begründungen finden.
Dann würde ich mich nicht beschweren.
Ähm und dann könnte das eben, könnte das ja sein, dass vielleicht der ein oder andere Kollege geneigt wäre zu sagen, jo, kein Thema.
Kriege ich hin, ich weiß, wie das geht, ich weiß, wie ich mich erwischt werde,
machen wir mal. Ähm oder andere sage ich mal Grau, Bereichshandlung könnte man sich vorstellen, dass so etwas äh auf einen Zug käme wie,
Ähm was weiß ich, jemand bietet Daten, die angeblich von uns sein könnten im Darknet an.
Wir würden uns würde interessieren, ob der wirklich in der Lage ist, zu liefern, damit wir wissen, ob wir hier eine größere, ob wir hier, ne, eine größere Forensik äh Initiative anstoßen müssen und ähm,
'ne Schadensbegrenzung in die Schadensbegrenzung gehen müssen könnte mal jemand ein Testkauf machen,
Auch das wäre in dem Fall natürlich illegal, weil du äh diese Daten, ne, die ja illegal da verkauft werden von Datenhehlern äh nicht so einfach kaufen darfst,
Auch da könnte sich die Frage stellen, ob man als Unternehmen oder als.
Erfüllungsgehefe, diese illegale Tätigkeit ausübt, ne? Diesen Datenhandel anstößt und die Kriminellen bezahlt oder,
äh oder nicht. Also es gibt quasi äh eine Reihe an Tätigkeiten in diesem Bereich, die legal nicht,
äh die die illegal wären.
Die aber unter Umständen hm ein Erkenntnisgewinn bringen würden und die vielleicht in einen Rahmen fallen könnten, den man.
Individuell, moralisch rechtfertigen könnte.
Du musst einen Jimsbon spielen, ne? Man nimmt das dann einfach mal selber in die Hand und guckt mal, was so geht.
Könnte ja ähm also könnte, ne, solche Situationen gibt es auf jeden Fall manchmal.
Ich äh ich nenne die Dis diese Situation deshalb, weil was in der Öffentlichkeit diskutiert wird, ist dann eher so ein,
aktiver Angriff auf äh das Strom auf die,
Stromversorgung in Deutschland, eine kriegerische Handlung. Ähm wir brauchen eine Ermächtigungsgrundlage, uns in diesem Fall zur Wehr zu setzen, quasi so live,
Live äh Rückhaking, ne? Das ist aber, also das halte ich eher für eine,
Ja halt, das halte ich eher für so ein äh schlechtes Beispiel, ne? Also so eine so wie ein Angriff auf ein Stromnetz ablaufen würde, würdest du wahrscheinlich eher die Angriffswelle stoppen und dir Gedanken ähm das irgendwie passiv defensiv machen
und dir dann darüber Gedanken machen, wie du deine Geräte wieder fix statt jetzt irgendwie
ihr was mit Hacking, wir hacken jetzt zurückzumachen, ne? Das also so Cyberware ist halt selten live Hacken dauert Zeit und,
deswegen glaube ich nicht, dass so ein Cyberrohr jetzt um unmittelbar und live verlaufen würde, insbesondere weil ja der schwierigste Teil dabei ist, zu erkennen.
Und zu atribuieren, von wem der Angriff kommt. Also wenn du jetzt sagst, okay, unser Stromnetz wird gerade lahmgelegt, dann äh müsstest du ja,
entweder sofort eine Schwachstelle in den Systemen haben, die den Angriff auf dich gerade ausüben, die kanntest du aber vorher nicht, das heißt, es ist sehr unwahrscheinlich, dass du bei denen eine Schwachstelle hast oder du müsstest attribuieren, alles klar, das sind äh die Belgier,
Als Rache für Belger kommen und ähm und jetzt machen wir Belgien platt,
Ja ähm und müsstest die schon quasi geound haben, um zu sagen, alles klar, eure Brennstäbe jetzt auch mal hoch,
und das beides wären eben eigentlich Szenarien, die ich,
ich sehr, sehr schwierig sehe und nicht in so einer Art Live Situation, sondern eher.
Übertrage, deswegen sind die Beispiele, die hier genannt werden, äh in der in der öffentlichen Diskussion glaube ich eher nicht ganz so einleuchtende. Und würde ich jetzt eher mal so keine Ahnung, Bundestagshack, man weiß ganz genau, wohin die Daten abgewandert sind,
Man weiß ja die IP-Adresse wohin äh wohin diese Gigabytes geschickt wurden. Man weiß nicht, welche Gigabytes das waren, was sich da drin befand. Also wäre es ja vielleicht eine interessante Aufgabe gewesen, den Kommanden Control Server zu,
zu ohnen und zu gucken, ob da noch Daten drauf liegen, um somit Erkenntnis über,
Das Ausmaß des Hackingangriffs und das Ziel des Hackingangriffs zu erlangen. Diskutiere.
Also ich sehe noch ein bisschen so eine unterschiedliche Diskussion, ob man jetzt hier über private äh Firmen und Individuen äh redet, wo es vielleicht eher so eine so eine ethisch moralische Frage ist in Kombination mit der aktuellen Gesetzgebung.
Und natürlich dann demwiefern,
verstehen wir vielleicht dieses Gewaltmonopol des Staates jetzt auch in so einem digitalen äh Rahmen. So ist so ein,
ein Rückschlag, ein Gegenhauen zur Verteidigung der digitalfreiheitlichen Grundordnung, ja? Äh.
Freie digitale Grundordnung.
Freien digitalen Grundordnung ist das sozusagen jetzt äh angemessen und und äh darf sowas zum Einsatz gebracht werden. Oben zum Beispiel größeren Schaden
vom Volk äh Staat, was auch immer zu nehmen, ne? So äh so Gefahr im Verzug,
ist ja dann auch so ein schönes Beispiel. Man muss ja mal was äh machen können. Jetzt kann man natürlich einige.
Sicherlich einige total unangemessene äh Vergleiche heranziehen, macht die Sache schon wirklich sehr schwierig. Zumal ja so dieser Gewaltvergleich,
bisschen was anderes ist, weil,
so einem Rechner rauspurzeln und irgendwie Blut lachen, das schon nochmal eine ganz andere Abteilung und lässt sich dieser Begriff nicht beliebig
miteinander vergleichen. Am Ende haben wir es ja dann doch eher mit technischen Systemen zu tun und eher mit so forensischen, detektivischen Tätigkeiten. Wenn's natürlich auch sein kann,
dass so ein Gegenschlag auch Infrastrukturen äh runterbringt und ähm ja,
zu Datenverlusten äh führt, die was weiß ich für welche Konsequenzen haben können? Schwierig. Also ich habe da noch nicht mal so richtig gut drüber nachgedacht, um ehrlich zu sein. Das ist ähm so ein Punkt.
Ich bin auch glaube ich immer noch so ein bisschen überrascht von diesem ganzen Cyber.
Tritt und eben. Also das das jetzt so dir, so ernsthaft so in so einer Breite ähm Einzug hält, ähm ja war wahrscheinlich,
absehbar, aber gehört zu diesen Dingen, wo man dann trotzdem irgendwie überrascht ist, wenn's äh wenn's dann tatsächlich passiert.
Ja wenn Diskussion dann richtig, ne? Also was jetzt geplant ist, ist bis zum Sommer soll es jetzt eine Expertenrunde
Unter Leitung des Innenministeriums und des Bundessicherheitsrats geben die Lösung vorliegt und das natürlich eben als Ermächtigungsgrundlage, welche Gesetze müssen ergänzt oder verändert werden?
Welche Behörde soll die Aufgabe zum Gegenschlag erhalten? Und ähm dem Maisier äh,
geht davon aus, dass das ein Thema bei den nächsten Koalitionsverhandlungen werden wird. Ne, das heißt, dass man eben wieder einen Koalitionsvertrag stehen hat, wir werden eine Ermächtigungsgrundlage für,
die hm für die Bundeswehr haben. Schön ist das, dem ist sehr davon ausgeht, dass er an den nächsten Koalitionsverhandlungen beteiligt ist.
Ja, kann schon sein.
Ähm ja.
Tja, keine Ahnung, was passiert da jetzt für eine digitale Leitkultur äh zum Einsatz bringen wollen und.
Noch ein kurzer Punkt. Das ist deswegen also nochmal um den, um den kompletten die gesetzliche Herausforderung zu sehen, Gefahrenabwehr ist äh nämlich Ländersache,
Und ähm die Bundesregierung hätte das aber natürlich gerne äh eine ausschließliche Zuständigkeit für den Bund,
Das heißt, äh wie bei der Wiederbehörde äußeren Verteidigung, das heißt, da werden die auch nochmal diskutieren müssen. Also rein juristisch ist das immer mal ein steiniger Weg und dicke Bretter, die mit dünnen Bohrern gebaut werden müssen.
Aber ich frage mich halt, also es ist echt äh ja, digitale Notwehr,
Zur Aufrechterhaltung der freiheitlich digitalen Grundordnung oder oder nicht.
Ich meine, wir haben ja nun auch genug äh Länder, um uns herum und um uns herum heißt ja im Prinzip egal, wo sie sich befinden auf diesem Planeten und weil jetzt eben diesen, diesen Grenzaspekt nicht mehr so haben.
Bisher konnte man sich immer wunderbar zurückziehen auf na ja wir wir sichern jetzt mal hier so unsere Region und jeder der tanzt noch böses will weiter als tausend Kilometer entfernt das sind der kann uns eigentlich auch mal am Arsch lecken.
Jetzt in digitalen Cyber äh Attacken Zeiten, wo dir im Prinzip,
Jede Insel in der Karibik äh ordentlich äh aufs aufs Fell gehen kann.
Hast du natürlich eine einfach auch eine ganz andere Krisensituation, eine ganz andere Krisenlage. So, auf einmal kann dir halt auch hier jeder,
Schaden auf einmal bist du im Prinzip die ganze Zeit in so einer,
Frontlinie, die ja nicht unbedingt jetzt nur primär von von Ländern ausgehen muss, sondern im Prinzip ja von jeglichen Kriminellen, so und am Ende ist das ja auch alles einfach nur kriminelles Verhalten, was äh hier an den Tag gelegt wird,
Also es ist auch eine interessante Vermischung aus.
Krieg es in Auseinandersetzungen zwischen Staaten oder zumindest von von Gruppen den Anspruch haben ein solcher zu sein und eben,
einzelnen Banden, weil hier wird ja quasi der kriegsähnliche Zustand kann ja schon hervorgerufen werden von zwei oder drei Gifted People oder vielleicht auch mal einer,
das setzt natürlich auch nochmal ganz andere Relationen hier in die ganze Debatte rein, die wir so bisher auch noch nicht gehabt haben,
wenn da irgendwelche Reichsbürger irgendwie so eine Insel auf der Donau,
und sagen so ja hier Bundesrepublik Deutschland nimmt dies, ja? Gut, da kann man dann halt noch ein bisschen drüber lachen so aber wenn sie halt neben nebenbei irgendwie die Datenbank aller Onlineshops irgendwie auch noch mitnehmen so dann wird das halt langsam seriös.
So und ja was macht man denn so mit dem mit den ganzen Drogen äh Lieferanten, die haben die die Gesellschaft zerstört, ne? Da werden dann halt die Plantagen abgebrannt, ne. Na ja, also.
Ist das so? Aber muss man ein bisschen weiter wegstellen.
Deutschland nicht ganz so der Standard so, aber Südamerika und äh Afghanistan, da hat man sowas hal.
Wir können das auch wie die Philippinen machen.
Also nicht nicht. Ja, doch irgendwann der äh ja.
Nur um mal den äh die Pole der Debatte hier zu ja auch zu zeigen.
Ja. Genau, was will, was, was, was würdest du Theate tun.
Das ist eigentlich die Antwort ist immer relativ klar.
Cyberto Theater.
Löschte ja wirklich jedes Bitt von der Platte.
Äh nicht lustig.
Nee, leider nicht. Trotzdem schon irgendwie am weißen Haus äh empfangen worden und gelobt worden für seine Aktivitäten. Schlimm, schlimm.
Also in in Vermischung mit dem Atributionsproblem. Ähm.
In Vermischung mit dem Problem, dass der Angriff selten vom Angreifer direkt kommt, sondern dass du gerne andere äh Server benutzt ähm.
Hast du halt hier echt eine sehr große Wahrscheinlichkeit am Ende den falschen anzugreifen.
Und ähm was ja auch immer beim beim Hacking eine Rolle spielt ist, dass du unter Umständen,
Oder ist du sehr schnell, soweit bist, dass du etwas über dich selber verrätst und über deine eigenen Fähigkeiten,
Wenn jetzt die Bundesregierung also so eine Hacking-Backen-Nummer hätte,
Ich glaube, ich würde als erstes irgendwie so eine, so ein, irgendwie mir so einen Server organisieren, der möglichst alles äh wegschreibt und weglockt, was ihm widerfährt.
Insbesondere an Angriffsversuchen und dann würde ich irgendwie so eine, was weiß ich, so eine Webseite dadrauf bauen, die die Möglichkeit zu allerlei.
Interessiertem äh Eingreiferverhalten bietet.
Hock mich, wenn du könnst.
Like und wird einfach alles wegschreiben, was mit dem Ding passiert. Und dann könnte ich quasi dadurch äh sehr einfach äh ableiten,
Wo stehen die Server der Bundeswehr, wenn die sich nicht der gleichen Methoden bedienen wie ich? Ähm was für Angriffe versuchen die, ne.
Welcher gegen welchen wären meine Server nicht gehärtet, wenn ich die gleichen Angriffe gegen meine fahre,
haben die O-Days, die äh die mir die mir nicht bekannt sind, die ich bei der Gelegenheit gerne einsammeln würde und äh verwenden könnte, um weiteren Hacksport zu betreiben. Ähm also da,
Lörder, da du hast da ja diese, das wird immer bei allem was mit mit Krieg und Cyber zu tun hat, werden immer so,
Merkt man, dass da halt die alten.
Die alten Militärstrategen irgendwie denken die meinen, dass sie durch den Einsatz einer Waffe irgendwie halt,
eine Stadt in Schutt und Asche äh versetzen und das dann auch so bleibt. Und das ist eben nicht so.
Und,
insofern ich, also ich finde das Thema interessant, ich glaube, wir haben's jetzt ein bisschen umrissen, aber eine Handlungsempfehlung,
würde ich da jetzt ungern aussprechen. Also ich glaube zu sagen, okay, wir machen eine, wir sagen prinzipiell unter keinen Umständen ist äh äh zurückhacken,
erlaubt? Ähm das könnte natürlich auch ins Auge gehen.
Gleichzeitig bei bei unserer Bundesregierung hast du Zweifelsfall ähm etwas, was.
Sehr weitreichende Befugnisse gibt, die in den Händen der falschen Leute zu sowohl deren eigenen Schaden als auch dem der Gesellschaft führen.
Also es ist auf jeden Fall mal ein sehr interessanter ähm eine sehr interessante Fragestellung hier für Feedback in unseren äh Kommentaren. Das würde mich mal wirklich interessieren so wie wie seht ihr das? Ja, denkt ihr es,
müsste so etwas wie eine digitale Notwehr äh Regelung geben, ja? Darf man,
darf man, darf man sozusagen zurückschlagen, wie kann man sowas später überhaupt belegen ohne selber in Probleme zu geraten? Was was sind so die Rahmenbedingungen, die man hier aufstellen sollte, auch jenseits eines,
ideal ist. Ja, ich denke, ein Ideal zu formulieren ist, fällt einem hier sehr einfach.
Aber das wiederum mit den realen Aktivitäten da draußen in Einklang zu bringen. Das ist glaube ich sehr schwierig. Wir haben's hier wirklich mit einer
Problematik zu tun, auf die es keine einfachen Antworten äh gibt und wo einfache Lösungen einfach noch nicht gesehen werden. Also außer vielleicht,
Donald Trump ähm hat da glaube ich noch keiner eine gesehen. Und du Terte vielleicht noch.
So, nenne ich mein nächstes Herr Hacking Tool.
Du Thertepunkt Exe.
So, dann war da irgendwas mit Streaming.
Streaming ist jetzt auch illegal.
Ach so.
Ne, ähm also es gibt ja einer der Weisheiten unter den Digitalsparfüchsen, ist ja das ähm.
Du, wenn du einen Tollen drunter lädst, äh das große Risiko äh eingehst, wenn du jetzt nicht irgendwie ein VPN gleichzeitig nutzt, dass du
gleichzeitig eben das Werk auch öffentlich machst und deswegen der öffentlichen zugänglichen Machung
belangt wirst und eine schöne Abmahnung bekommst, weil du dich dieser schuldig gemacht hast. Das heißt, du wirst nicht abgemahnt, weil du,
den das Video runtergeladen hast, sondern weil du es anderen ermöglicht hast es runterzuladen.
Und eine schöne ähm.
Möglichkeit, diesem juristischen Gefüge zu entgehen, ist das Nutzen sogenannter
Streaminganbieter, die sich die quasi die Last des illegalen auf sich nehmen beziehungsweise auf ihre Briefkastenfirma, auf den Schellen
Ähm und es dir im Gegenzug äh oder für den kleinen Obolus einiger Malware-Infektionen auf deinem Rechner kostenlos ermöglichen äh diese diese brandneuen Kino.
Hits zu gucken. Und ähm wer solche Anbieter nutzt,
konnte bisher in Deutschland ähm ruhig schlafen, solange eben diese Myway-Infektionen kein größeres Problem für ihn waren, äh weil man eben,
sich zumindest zumindest rechtlich nicht für den Konsum belangt werden konnte. Ähm.
Diese Situation bewog einen äh ein ein Anbieter,
dazu ein multimedialen Medienabspieler für Fernseher anzubieten, der vorinstallierte hatte, die,
das betrachten von Streaming aus fragwürdigen Fällen ermöglichen.
Man merkt ich wachse, ich wechsele jetzt langsam in die Juristensprecht, das war jetzt gerade.
Das ist aber die schönsten Momente.
Zitat aus dem Artikel von Markus Kompa. Ähm.
Der konstatierste diese Geräte sich außerordentlich gut verkauft haben. Also ein Gerät, auf dem steht hier eingebaut, was weiß ich,
Kino XTO äh auf einen Klick äh mit entsprechender Taste auf der Fernbedienung oder so, ne? Und es wurde also auch so beworben, dass äh dieses Gerät.
Diese Funktion hat. Ja, also hier ein so. Und.
Jetzt hat das Gericht dann eben äh entschieden, in diesem Fall der EuGH, dass dies eine, also diese Funktionalität
explizit zu bewerben, eine bedeutsame Handlung ist, die der öffentlichen Wiedergabe gleichzustellen ist
also der Verkauf, die dieser Medienplayer, die einen einfachen Zugang zu illegalen Streaming-Angeboten ermöglicht, selbst eine öffentliche Wiedergabe im Urheberrechtlichen Sinne beinhaltet und damit eine Urheberrechtsverletzung darstellt. Das heißt, du darfst diese Dinger
nicht verkaufen. Ähm und ich glaube.
Es ist ähm unser Freund von Internet Law, nämlich der Thomas,
Stadler, der dann sagt, äh der EuGH kommt zu dem Ergebnis, dass der Nutzer, der Urheberrechtswidrige Inhalt es streamt, sich nicht darauf berufen kann, dass er damit eine vom Gesetz priviligierte Zwischenspeicherung vornimmt,
Der Nutzer, der urheberrechtswidrige Inhalt es streamt, verletzt also selbst das Urreheberecht, selbst dann
jedenfalls dann, wenn er sich freiwillig und im Kenntnis der Sachlage Zugang zu einem kostenlosen, nicht zugelassenen Angebot
geschützter Werke verschafft. Und das war eben früher so, dass man gesagt hat, es ist nur eine Zwischenspeicherung, du hast es nicht wirklich selber äh
kopiert.
Und Sonne hast es nur angeguckt, du hast ja nur ein Angebot konsumiert und derjenige, der es angeboten hat, ist der Böse. Und hier wird eben gesagt, wenn du, wenn du es aber weißt und äh ihn kennt, ist der Sachlage tust, dann kannst du trotzdem,
belangt werden,
Gleichzeitig kommen aber kommt Markus Kompa eher zu dem Ergebnis nachher eine Abmahnwelle ist aber dennoch unwahrscheinlich, weil es ja eben schwer nachzuweisen ist, dass du diese, dass du diese Streams konsumiert hast,
Also die äh Abmahnungen gehen deshalb raus, weil es sehr einfach ist, sich einfach in so ein Tourentworm Schwarm, in einen Tonnenschwarm einzuklinken,
einfach alle IP-Adressen, die einem der Datenpakete schicken, mitzuschreiben und die dann eben automatisiert feststellen zu lassen.
Und äh automatisiert abzumahnen und automatisiert auf dem Konto den Zahlungseingang zu verzeichnen. Deswegen kannst du da halt schön automatisierte Abmahnwellen machen. In diesem Fall diese Streamings musst du ja immer noch,
eine IP-Verbindung zwischen.
Diesem Anbieter, dessen du ja ohnehin nicht habt wirst und dem Konsumenten nachweisen. Und es gibt eigentlich nur einen Fall, in dem das mal jemand versucht hat und die sind ja am Ende vor Gericht gescheitert. Du erinnerst dich, Tim.
Was ist das mit der Familie? Äh.
Ich weiß nicht, ob deine Familie äh betroffen war, aber es war diese Rettung Geschichte. Also war ein.
Das wurde ja von der anderen Seite aufgezogen, da haben sie ja ähm zahlreichen Leuten unterstellt, sie hätten das getan und so konnten keinerlei
klares technisches Protokoll vorliegen, wie diese IP-Adressen wirklich rangekommen sind. Das war ohnehin Fishi. Ich frage mich halt jetzt nur,
jetzt so 'ne Box zu Hause hat und ein ein illegaler Videostrom kommt quasi in den Heimanschluss rein welcher Nutzer denn dann letzten Endes für die Urheberrechtsverletzung äh
Dingbar gemacht werden würde, wer hat denn letzten Endes geguckt.
Na, da sind wir ja wieder bei einem anderen Fall der Rechtssprechung, wo wir jetzt vor vor wenigen Wochen behandelt haben, dass äh wieder das Verhältnis zwischen Eltern und Kindern, zum Beispiel im Haushalt ist, ne? Unter welchen Bedingungen der ähm.
Nur wenn du's weißt, musst du's sagen.
Genau.
Unter welchen Bedingungen eben der Anschlussinhaber als Störer haftet, unter welchen Bedingungen nicht. Ähm da werden wir dann im Rahmen der normalen Rechtssprechung. Bei Rettung übrigens, ich glaube, wenn ich das Recht im Sinne war, haben wir das natürlich über, wie macht man sowas über Werbeanzeigen gemacht, ne? Also würde ich
von ausgehen. Dass die äh entsprechende Werbung geschaltet haben oder ähm,
Ja, also so würde so würde ich das machen. Ich würde bei meinen Videos bei Retube werben und entsprechend dann die Zugriffe auf die Werbeanzeige protokollieren und sagen, die habe ich nur da geschaltet. Also, dass du das geguckt.
Weiß ich, ich weiß nicht mehr genau, wer bei uns äh auf Logbuch Netzpolitik DE Reduke sucht, der wird äh eine genauere Analyse dieses Falles.
Genau, wir wussten das alles schon mal besser.
Ja, aber also rechtlich rechtlich ist die Situation von Streaming äh illegalen Streaming-Betrachtern jetzt eine andere faktisch praktisch wird sie sich vermutlich erstmal in naher Zukunft nicht ändern.
Ähm aber man sollte das im Auge behalten und generell ist, glaube ich, die Nutzung solcher illegalen Streamingangebote
aus Richt aus also ohne ohne ernst zu nehmende Security-Konzept auf deinem Rechner,
oder zumindest für deinen Browser sowieso nur den den ganz äh harten zu empfehlen.
So dann gibt's hier noch so ein äh Webprojekt, woher so das eigentlich hier.
Oh, das wurde mir zugetragen.
Das wurde dir zugetragen. Ja, sieht hier nach einem, nach einem kleinen Digitalprojekt aus, wo Überwachungskameras katografiert werden sollen. Das Ganze lauert unter der Domain Juvenal Punkt org.
Ist offensichtlich inspiriert von den G zwanzig Treffen, was demnächst in.
Hamburg, ja.
Ansteht
und wir beobachten ja schon seit längerem eine Zunahme an äh installierten Überwachungskameras und privaten örtlichen Gebäuden, teilweise eben auch im öffentlichen Raum
Das ist ja mittlerweile eine hochverfügbare Technologie, die sehr günstig ist und ähm,
Es war die Frage, wie begegnet man denn jetzt nun diesen
anwachsen und offensichtlich haben die Betreiber dieser Webseite hier einfach mal den Crowdfourcing Aspekt gewählt, sprich Juvenal Punkt Ox, eine Webseite, wo man selber Bilder hochladen kann
Das äh wird dann quasi auf eine Open Street Mag Open Street Map Karte eingeblendet und man ähm,
hat quasi mit dem Foto ja seinen Eokoordinate, kann dann interaktiv genau platzieren, wo jetzt diese Überwachungskamera ist,
Wenn ich das richtig sehe ist so das Ziel so ein bisschen auch äh nicht nur überhaupt zu katografieren, wo ist etwas, ähm letzten Endes auch so ein bisschen über die Zeit den äh Zuwachs,
an Überwachung oder an geänderten Positionen mit zu äh diskutieren.
Also den geht's insbesondere darum mit der Veranstaltung des G zwanzig Gipfels in Hamburg wir werden natürlich,
enorme Sicherheitsmaßnahmen
gerade in dieser Stadt ausgerollt. Also du kannst dir heute schon in Hamburg irgendwie die Polizeicamps da anschauen, das ist irgendwie ein riesen Projekt. Die rollen also wirklich irgendwie von Funküberwachung, irgendwie allen möglichen Mistrollen, die in dieser Stadt aus,
irgendwie ähm,
sicherzustellen, dass da ähm von den paar Personen, die sich da unterhalten, niemand zu Schaden kommt ähm oder auch kein täglicher Angriff äh auf diese Menschen passiert.
Und ähm Sicherheit heißt eben nicht nur Bewaffnung, Mauern und Knüppel, sondern Sicherheit heißt eben auch äh Videoüberwachung
Funküberwachung und ähnliche Scherze. Und das wird jetzt alles irgendwie grade schön in Hamburg installiert und es ist eben davon auszugehen, dass es einen größeren ähm Zuwachs an
Videoüberwachungstechnik in dieser Stadt geben wird. Während sich die gleichzeitig die Frage stellt, wird das denn eigentlich auch am Ende wieder abgebaut,
Und wollen wir denn mal diese ganze Videoüberwachungstechnik hier
Mike Cartheografieren, um das mal zu dokumentieren, wo das überhaupt alles stattfindet. Und der Weg, den sie da gewählt haben, ist, also finde ich einfach schön und elegant. Du läufst irgendwie durch die Stadt
Findest eine Überwachungskamera und du machst einfach nur ein Foto mit deinem Smartphone. Von dieser Kamera.
In die die Smartphones schreiben ja dann die Accifed Daten, wo sich diese Kamera befindet äh in die Access-Daten ohnehin die GPS-Daten, wo sich diese Kamera befindet
Und diese Fotos lädst du dann einfach hoch. Wenn dein Telefon da kein GPS reinschreibt, dann äh letztes, schreibst
Markierst du halt noch eben auf dem Punkt, wo das ist. Und ähm dann siehst du eben auf der,
Auf der Karte bei Juvenal Punkt org, dass da eine Kamera ist und äh du siehst auch schön ähm,
Ne, welcher, welcher Teil dann davon erfasst wird. Und die konzentrieren sich jetzt
Erstmal auf Hamburg, weil das eben aufgrund des G zwanzig Gipfels da das äh das Interessanteste ist. Äh die kontrollieren diese Daten auch noch ähm manuell. Das heißt äh ähm es wird.
Nur bestätigte Kameras werden dort eingetragen. Es gibt so eine so ein Ziel, dass diese Kameras von einer zweiten Person dann bestätigt werden sollen, um eben da die die Datenhygiene zu pflegen. Und dann hast du irgendwann eine ein Open Street Mappen Layer, was du
nutzen kannst.
Ähm zum Beispiel um deinen Überwachungsfreien Spaziergang durch die Hamburger äh Innenstadt zu ermöglichen, was sich jetzt hier allgemein äh schon mit den wenigen bis jetzt gesammelten Karten für allgemein.
Unmöglich handel äh halte,
Also müsste auf jeden Fall jetzt große Umwege gehen. Wenn du nicht von irgendeiner Video Videokamera beacht werden möchtest. Das Ganze hat natürlich auch ähm eine.
Ähm eine rechtliche Komponente, denn so einfach äh und so erlaubt ist das ja gar nicht einfach überall die die Öffentlichkeit mit Videokameras zu überwachen.
Also da gibt es rechtliche Einschränkungen und äh das sollte hier äh auch.
Anerkennung finden, insofern finde ich das ein sehr ähm förderungswertes Projekt, das wie gesagt.
Sich hier erstmal auf Hamburg beschränkt.
Und insbesondere im Rahmen des G zwanzig Gipfels stattfindet, ich kann mir aber sehr gut vorstellen, dass ähm die äh Betreiber dieser Seite jetzt gar nicht so abgeneigt werden, wenn sich da Menschen finden würden, die sagen, okay, wir ähm
übernehmende Patenschaft für eine andere Stadt oder so. Aber das wäre, glaube ich, eher erst in der
Zukunft der Fall. Im Moment ist das relativ simpel, Hamburg, Kameras fotografieren, hochladen.
Und die Hydra sammeln.
So, jetzt musst du mir noch sagen, Tim, du hast das alles schon gut rausgesucht und ich bin ja, ich habe ja kein Latein gelernt, was ist denn, warum steht der Juwel nahe.
Ich habe auch kein Latein gelernt.
Du hast es nur gegoogelt oder was?
Na ja, ich ähm bediene mich natürlich auch das Unternehmen. Also Juvenal.
Ist ein alter römischer Satiriker und den kennt man,
Vermutlich weniger über seinen Namen, aber deutlich mehr über so ein paar äh dauerhafter äh Aussprüche. Also.
Von dem sind die klauen Sprüche. Die die schlauen Sprüche.
Von dem sind die schlauen äh Sprüche und einer dieser schlauen Sprüche ist ja hier auch im äh Titel des äh dieser Websitenprojektes, also ich
bin auch mittlertanischer Aussprache nicht gut, aber ich sage mal, hier sind Quiz kurz todiert, ipsos, Custodes.
Wer überwacht die Überwacher?
Genau oder wer aber soll die Wächter selbst bewachen, das kann man auf diese oder jede Art und Weise ähm äh übersetzen.
Das ist sozusagen ein Klassiker, der von ihm kommt, auch Panim at Zirzenses, also dieses Brot und Spiele äh Ding wird ihm
zugeschrieben oder dass ein gesunder Geist in einem gesunden Körper äh zu sein hat oder sich dort findet oder wie auch immer. Ähm,
Auch das ist von ihm, was ich noch überhaupt nicht kannte, aber was ich irgendwie ganz lustig finde, weil das bei uns auch irgendwie so ein bisschen wiederkehrendes Thema ist.
Ein gesunder Geist in deinem gesunden Körper? Na, ach so, nee, nee, das Stiel bei uns keine Rolle.
Defizite ist Satura, Nones Kribere. Es ist schwierig, keine Satire zu schreiben. Und das fand ich dann so als,
als als das können wir uns fast so als Subtitel irgendwie für diesen Podcast äh.
Nochmal das Schreiben in ein Senden oder sagen ummünzen.
Da äh wer sich, wer sich in Latein ähm gut zurechtfindet, ich hatte kein Latein in der Schule,
Können's ja vielleicht mal sagen, wie wir daraus hier eine ordentliche Tackline ins Politik machen
denn es ist nun wirklich schwierig, keine Satire. Über all das zu machen, mit dem wir uns hier äh beschäftigen. Nicht, dass wir uns für die größten Satire halten, aber so ein bisschen das Lachen vergibt, ja dann irgendwie dann doch nicht.
Ja, also Hamburger, ihr seid gefordert.
Wie ihr die Webseite stütz.
Geforderung. Dann bleibt uns eigentlich nur vor den Terminen.
Eine Kurzmeldung, das EID-Gesetz von uns ja noch in der letzten Sendung gescholten, ebenfalls von der Stellungnahme des CC eine gescholten.
Und überhaupt eigentlich rundum Gescholten.
Immer nur geschollten, einfach mist ähm.
Wurde von der Tagesordnung des Bundestages genommen, eigentlich sollte das in der Nacht von Donnerstag auf Freitag um ein Uhr dreißig zum zweiten Mal debattiert und anschließend verabschiedet werden.
Sind aber alle eingeschlagen, schafft vorher wahrscheinlich.
Das sind Leute, die gehen um miteinander. Das soll nun nicht mehr, sondern in der nächsten Sitzungswoche und die findet Mitte Mai statt geschehen.
Ähm man kann jetzt nur darüber spekulieren, dass äh dass auch daran liegt, dass es große Bedenken von Datenschützern äh in der in der Anhörung im Innenausschuss gab. Ähm.
Und der SPD-Indexperte Machmut Özdemir sagt, ja das ist von der Tagesordnung genommen, ich wollte ganz bewusst kein Eile, wir haben Redebedarf und jetzt reden wir die Union ist mir da gefolgt.
Äh wollten sie waren so orientierungslos, dass sie äh nicht dran glaubten, dass sie das noch durchkriegen.
Also es gibt jetzt man kann hoffen, dass sie da vielleicht auf Kritikpunkte eingehen, ja? Das ähm wäre doch mal was.
Die Hoffnung stirbt zuletzt, ja. Ja. Ja. Gut. Das äh bringt uns dann so folgendem Segment.
Nämlich den Terminen.
Den Termin, wir fangen an direkt mit dem Thema Juwenal nochmal. Am sechzehnten Mai zweitausendsiebzehn äh gibt es einen Touchsalon in Hamburg im Haus
Dreiundsiebzig am Schulterblatt dreiundsiebzig, der sich mit diesen ähm,
Thema Auseinandersetzung wird ähm und wo auch ein Vertreter des Projektes vor Ort sein wird. Bis dahin könnt ihr schon mal schön gesammelt haben.
Ja und in,
Österreich da äh sammelt sich ein wenig der äh Widerstand, zu dem hier vor einigen Sendungen bereits ausführlich diskutierten Überwachungs
was äh noch nicht äh in trockenen Tüchern zu sein scheint, was ja äh beruhigend ist und dort gibt es
Stammtische gegen das Überwachungspaket, das klingt das klingt ganz gut, das sollten wir vielleicht hier auch mal einführen, sowas,
deutsche Stammtische gegen Vorratsdatenspeicherung. Ähm ja,
organisiert, koordiniert auf EP-Center, Works, äh, dort haben wir einen Link, wo ihr Termine finden könnt für treffenden Graz, Linz, Innsbruck, Feldkirch, Salzburg, Villach, Krems, Wien und,
Wiener Neustadt, wo auch immer da der Unterschied liegen mag. Wir wissen es nicht, aber ihr wisst es besser. Könnt ihr einfach mal nachschlagen.
Details gab's in Logbuchnetzpolitik zweihundertvierzehn. Wer was dagegen tun will. Kommt zum Stammtisch, vernetzt sich und wird aktiv.
Im, auch im Mai, meine Güte, auch im Mai, der Vonoven Monat äh fünfundzwanzigster bis achtundzwanzigster Mai in Karlsruhe findet mal wieder die Gulasch-Programmiernacht statt. Das ist ein viertägiger Kongress, der vom,
Tropia EV ausgerichtet wird. Das ist die äh CC-Niederlassung in Karlsruhe,
und der Name GPN ist wörtlich zu nehmen, denn immer wieder schafft es auch einen Haufen Hacker, eine große Menge Gulasch zuzubereiten, um die Gäste zu nähren, damit sie gestärkt zum nächsten Vortrag. Über Programmierung oder Gesellschaft oder zum Programmieren
ins Hacklabor. Äh ins Hack Center gehen können. Ähm,
Wir haben den die allgemeine Ankündigung und den Käuf Portestipation verlinkt. Ich hoffe, der ist überhaupt noch offen. Ähm aber da kann man glaube ich sehr gut hingehen. Ähm wenn ich das richtig erinnere, ist der Eintritt frei.
Und äh das Ganze findet in echt auch ganz schönen Räumlichkeiten statt. Da in Karlsruhe.
Ganze über Pfingsten, fünfundzwanzigster bis achtundzwanzigster Mai.
Ja, Pfingsten, sowas sind doch christliche Kategorien.
Ja. Sind sie. Aber.
Das ist der Termin,
Ein weiterer Termin gibt es, hatten wir hier letztes Mal schon angedeutet, die G dreiundzwanzig quasi so ein äh alternativer äh Aktivisten
Kongress hier rund um die G zwanzig Inspiration in Berlin.
Und ähm ja, sagt auch nochmal ein bisschen was dazu. Wer da äh sich eigentlich noch als Teilnehmer melden sollte und auf welche Art und Weise man noch teilnehmen kann.
Also, teilnehmen sollen wir zur Teilnahme ermutigt, sind natürlich alle politisch Interessierten künstlerisch und kulturell interessiert, die da die Gelegenheit zur Vernetzung nutzen möchten,
Ähm ich glaube, das wird ein, also es ist ein relativ offenes Programm, so Barcamp mäßig mit zwanzig Minuten Slots, wir haben eine sehr schöne Gruppe an Moderatorinnen, die uns da durch den Abend führen, äh durch den Tag,
führen werden. Los geht's am Freitag neunzehn Uhr, Samstag, tagsüber komplett und dann eben am Samstagabend so ab einundzwanzig Uhr gibt's dann eben,
die Party noch.
Und am Sonntag werden ähm steht auf dem Programm Katerfrühstück und Bandenbildung.
Weil die Partys nochmal so separat oder wie.
Die Party ist deshalb separat, weil ja nicht vielleicht alle Lust haben, sich das gesamte Wochenende diesem Kongress zu widmen,
ne? Und wir natürlich trotzdem schön feiern wollen in einer coolen Runde und deswegen gibt es die Möglichkeit auch nur die Party zu besuchen für diejenigen die sagen OK komm
mich da drei Tage einzusperren mit den verrückten ähm habe ich keinen Bock drauf, aber schon kann ich mal mit hintrinken so, ne? Ähm aber selbstverständlich soll niemand, der
an dieser Veranstaltung teilnehmen möchte, sich entmutigt fühlen, weil er jetzt nicht der Premiumaktivist ist und noch nicht genug Kerben im,
hat und meint deswegen sei er da nicht gerne gesehen, ne? Wer Lust hat, etwas zu tun und sich zu engagieren, ist da herzlich eingeladen zu kommen.
Und heiße Aktivisten warten auf dich an der Bar.
Werden wir sehen.
Komm ran.
Ne? Und Samstagabend, Samstagabend Party am Holzmarkt ähm ich glaube, man kann jetzt so schon so ein bisschen vom Line-up sprechen,
Ähm Stil und Bense werden da sein
hier natürlich bekannt als insbesondere durch Arne Benze, der ja nicht nur einmal den ein oder anderen Klassiker, der der Cybermusik äh geschrieben hat,
wird dort sein mit sein.
Mit seinem Kollegen, wo die zusammen so DJ, Musik und äh Naturmusik machen, also also DJ in Begleitung von Live-Gitarre, geiler Scheiß so.
Tourmusik.
Ja, was weiß ich.
Golden Music.
Ähm.
Ähm jetzt muss ich mal ganz kurz schauen. Also Tasmo wird auch da sein, der ist in Berlin, denke ich, auch kein Unbekannter mehr, ganz im Gegenteil. Und ähm.
Jetzt will ich Linus schreiben, weil das Wort ist Line-up, habe ich das Line-up nicht mehr hier offen. Das gibt es doch nicht. Hier das mit diesen Tabs, es muss auch mal irgendwie jemand lösen.
Na hier steht noch was.
Hast du ja, aber ich habe ähm ich finde den.
Super Vorwärt.
Ja, Lein, Line-Up, G dreiundzwanzig.
Haben jetzt richtig steil. Partymodus jetzt.
Sorry. Jetzt geht es hier auch noch mit Groß und Kleinschreibung.
Das ist ja auch alles so schwierig.
Für unsere für unsere Hörenden sollte aber reichen, dass wir sagen Tasmo und Stil und Benzel sind da und Samstag und Sonntag gibt's auch Musik und Gregor spielt und so. Das wird ein ähm wird ein Fest.
Gut. Dann machen wir jetzt hier mal Deckel drauf. Hast du noch Danksagungen zu verkünden.
Ja endlich, ich hatte ja letzte Woche das das Zettelchen vergessen. Ich danke Robin, Jan, Markus und Peter.
Und ich danke wie immer auch allen anderen, die hier zuhören mitgestalten, mitkommentieren, gute Ideen äh liefern auf allen bedenklichen Kanälen. Vielleicht
sieht man sich auf dem G dreiundzwanzig an diesem Wochenende oder auf der Party äh an diesem Wochenende,
Da werden wir sicherlich auch vertreten sein. So und ansonsten hören wir uns nächste Woche. Wahrscheinlich.
Gucken, wenn die, wenn hier weiter Cyber wird, müssen wir ja, irgendwie müssen wir wieder ran.
Genau, wir zabern euch ja hier weiterhin richtig durch. Richtig durchsalbern hier alle. Oh weia, die Sendung muss enden. Wir sagen tschüss. Ciao, ciao.
Ciao ciao.